after 18 months of negotiations and
last-minute concessions from member
states EU ministers of employment and
Social Affairs lived up to expectations
and agreed a compromise on how to
regulate workers posted from one EU
member state to another the new rules
which still need to be negotiated with
the European Parliament aim at better
protecting workers who are temporarily
posted abroad by their employers by
ensuring that minimum social rights are
respected it is a very important
agreement that will benefit all Member
States regardless of whether they are
hosting or sending member states posting
is key in such sectors as construction
agriculture transport and the IT
industry under the deal host Member
States would be free to decide the
verification measures to be imposed on
companies posting workers subject to
these requirements and controls being
proportionate and the European
Commission having been notified the
council also took stock of initiatives
fostering youth employment in the
different countries and exchange views
on the European semester 2014 in the
field of employment and social policy
finally the Lithuanian presidency of the
council inform ministers about the state
of play in negotiations on future EU
tobacco rules despite the split over
e-cigarettes both presidency and
Commission are still hoping for an
agreement before the end of the year